[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous suivre en
direct sur figaro live on attend vos
points de vue sur les sujets d'actualité
dont nous allons débattre aujourd'hui en
plateau leur confinement évidemment avec
ses conséquences économiques mais aussi
évidemment l'attentât qui a frappé la
ville de nice ce matin trois personnes
ont trouvé la mort après avoir été
agressé à l'armé blanche à la basilique
notre-dame dans le centre ville de nice
par un homme qui a ensuite été
interpellé par la police cet acte
terroriste au cours duquel son auteur
aurait crié allah ouakbar plusieurs fois
fait de nouveau s'interroger quelle
réplique face au terrorisme at on
réellement les moyens de lutter contre
ce type d'attentât faut-il se résigner à
vivre avec cette menace permanente
doit-on craindre la multiplication
d'actes terroristes sur le territoire
français c'est la question qu'on vous
pose sur lefigaro.fr pardon sur twitter
on vous pose cette question sur les
réseaux sociaux du figaro et le conte
figaro live répondait idée maintenant
vous donnera vos réponses à la fin de ce
premier débat
on en débat donc aujourd'hui de cette
question des attentats et des actes
terroristes avec lucile schmid bonjour
lucile merci d'être un peu en direct
avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes ex
conseiller régional d'île de france ps
membre du conseil de rédaction de la
revue esprit cofondatrice et présidente
et vice président de farre don de la
fondation la fabrique économique
face à vous renée fregosi bonjour rené
philosophe et politologue je le rappelle
votre dernier ouvrage français encore un
effort pour les pour ester laïque est
édité aux éditions l'harmattan
merci également rené d'avoir accepté
notre invitation de nouveau la violence
et la barbarie quelques jours après
l'assassinât du professeur samuel pâti à
conflans-sainte-honorine dans les
yvelines
cette fois ci c'est à nice ce matin que
s'est produit cet acte terroriste trois
personnes assassinées je le rappelle
dont le sacristain de la basilique
le parquet antiterroriste a été saisie
écoutez comment le maire de nice tu et
christian parent dont christian estrosi
a réagi juste après l'événement
comme la france est peut être plus que
d'autres lieux de france aujourd'hui est
en train de payer un tribut beaucoup
trop lourd en étant une fois de plus
victime de l'islamo fascisme
il ne fait aucun doute que l'auteur de
ces actes qui n'a cessé de répéter en
boucle devant nous allahou akbar alors
qu'il été médicalisé sur place
quel était le sens de son geste
lucile schmid c'est un acte à associer
au contexte antifrançais et anti-
charlie qu'on vit ses dernières semaines
c'est clair c'est un acte d'imitation de
ce qui s'est passé avec sa mère pattie
c'est à dire qu'on voit bien que la
décapitation de sa mère pattie a
entraîné peut être perçu comme un modèle
par d'autres et c'est un jeune homme
c'est un homme un jeune homme de 18 ans
qui a assassiné sa mère pattie hélas ce
que je comprends c'est que c'est un
jeune homme doit également un jeune
homme de 21 ans qui est qui et qui a tué
qui a assassiné trois personnes donc il
ya un effet d'imitation
il ya aussi un contexte je trouve qui
n'est plus seulement nationale qui est
international avec ce qui vient de se
passer avec les prises de position
d'erdogan donc qui dirige la turquie
avec un certain nombre de positions qui
ont été prises dans certains états
musulmans et donc on perçoit bien la
difficulté
enfin je moi je vais je vais vous avouer
une chose c'est que je ne sais pas très
bien quelle peut être la réponse c'est à
dire qu' il ya des problèmes insolubles
en mathématiques j'ai le sentiment que
ça peut exister aussi sur le plan de ces
assassinats et qu'on voit bien
l'entremêlement entre le fait que des
hommes extrêmement jeunes deviennent des
assassins et quelque part se condamne
même si en faisant ce genre de choses
qu'il soit sur le sol français qu'ils
soient musulmans qu'ils tuent au nom
d'allah que par ailleurs une sorte
d'internationale
d'appels à une sorte de guerre en fait
entre
est un musulman et étapes qui sont des
états laïcs
arrive porté par dogan à partir de là
moi j'essaie de garder aussi mon
sang-froid et j'étais assez frappé que
du côté des autorités ecclésiastiques
il ya eu une condamnation absolument
sans appel et un appel à la fraternité
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut dans ce
moment comment est ce qu'on peut parler
de fraternité c'est difficile à imaginer
mais c'est aussi une sorte d' équilibre
que j'ai envie de garder dans ma tête
psychologiquement
tout en me disant mais comment est-ce
qu'on trouve des solutions
opérationnelles et j'ai pas envie de
vous sortir de solutions préfabriquées
comme l'islam au fascisme
ça sert à rien de condamner
l'islamo-fascisme si par ailleurs on n'a
pas des solutions opérationnelles à
proposer on verra on verra sur sur les
solutions dans un second temps
lussier schmitt renée fregosi parler
d'acte d'imitation et d'un appel à la
guerre depuis l'étranger oui mais c'est
pas seulement une limitation de
l'assassinât de la décapitation de d1
mais elle pâtit c'est l'ensemble de ces
attaques au couteau sont à mettre sous
lui ce qu'on a appelé très souvent les
attentats low cost c'est à dire en fait
c'est le djihad décentralisée
c'est ce qui a été théorisée par le
syrien al sourit ce jihad réalisé par
des individus donc très difficilement
repérables avec des moyens très simples
la maison de la danse au long de ces
armes blanches mais hélas très efficace
et c'est effectivement une guerre c'est
pas une sorte de guerre c'est une guerre
qui est déclarée à la france tout
spécialement parce que nous sommes un
pays très laïc mais plus globalement à
l'occident et cette idéologie est ce
mouvement qui est effectivement un
mouvement transnational peut-être même
plus qu international l'islamisme ce
nouveau totalitarisme c'est à la fois un
mouvement politique avec des activistes
avec des terroristes mais aussi avec des
théoriciens avec toute une idéologie une
idéologie globalement anti occidental et
pour l'occident c'est à la fois la
chrétienté
mais aussi le judaïsme mais aussi la
démocratie la laïcité c'est tout ça
ensemble
ce qui est vrai l'occident c'est tout ça
on s'en remet fregosi ce que vous dites
est intéressant parce que ça me permet
de rebondir sur deux tweets qui sont
parus ce matin là de notre consoeur
sonia mabrouk qui utilise le terme de
civilisation
ce qui est visé ce ne sont pas seulement
des valeurs la laïcité c'est une
civilisation qui est également visé et
nicolas sarkozy a posté également un
tweet dans lequel il dit
le temps n'est pas à la polémique ni à
la politique il est au combat de tous
contre la barbarie et pour la
civilisation on peut parler de
civilisation de guerre contre la
civilisation selon vous lis et schmidt
je sais pas ce dont on peut parler
j'avoue que par rapport à ce que vous
venez me rené je pense que ce jeune
homme qui a commis cet acte terrible je
suis pas sûr qu'ils savaient tout ça
c'est à dire que je pense qu'il y à
aussi un terreau chez des jeunes sommes
marginalisés musulmans qui se réfugie
dans une sorte d'héroïsme morbide et moi
ce qui me frappe c'est qu'en fait nos
mots pour dire ce qui se passe c'est
sans doute à combat de civilisation pour
nous mais je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit
leurs mots enfin je ne sais pas comment
le dire mais il ya une forme de
désespérance entre ce jeune tchétchène
je termine ce que j'ai à dire ce qui se
passe avec ce jeune tunisien qui
apparemment était sans papiers
totalement paumé donc on peut théoriser
on peut se dire que les choses ressemble
à ce qui se passait du temps des
croisades
on peut dire ce genre de choses sur le
dos enfin moi ce qui me frappe c'est
qu'il ya sans doute beaucoup de
possibilités que de jeunes hommes
continuent à passer à l'acte que
s'acheter un couteau c'est très simple
et que là il ya il ya moi j'ai peur
enfin je veux dire comme je pense c'est
à dire que
je n'ai je n'ai pas forcément envie de
théoriser sur la civilisation ou sûr
mais je pense qu'il ya un sentiment de
peur qui se répand dans la société
française et que cette question
d'imaginer que tout musulman peut
devenir un terroriste est aussi quelque
chose qui peut nous séparer alors même
que nous sommes le pays d'europe qui à
la communauté musulmane la plus la plus
importante donc je trouve que ça pose un
vrai un vrai problème de politique
intérieure sur lequel on n'a pas
forcément de réponses et sur lequel il
peut y avoir des choses qui viennent de
l'étranger
rené flosi je voudrais la direction qui
dit qu'elle avait avant d'en arrêter
d'avoir peur
on a tous peur j'imagine mais je veux
dire les résistants aussi avait peur je
pense qu' il ne s'agit pas de mettre en
place une politique d'apaisement désarmé
mais de résistance armée et surtout de
réarmement moral c'est pour ça bien sûr
si on prend la question de chaque
assassinat du point de vue des individus
moi je suis humaniste donc bien entendu
chaque individu compter chaque individu
a ses propres raisons et surtout des
raisons en l'occurrence 1 mais il faut
bien voir et vous l'avez dit vous même
s'il y a ressemblance entre tous et tous
ces attentats
c'est bien qu'il ya un système global
derrière et on sait bien de quoi il
s'agit l'islamisme est un mouvement
politique qui est à l'offensive depuis
de longues années mais qui s'est
réactivé avec la perte d' influence des
régimes nationalistes autoritaires
arabes notamment qui a repris de
l'importance et qui grâce à nos
immigration s'infiltre à l'intérieur de
ces populations qui sont souvent
fragilisés en effet individuellement et
les instrumentalise pour nous pour nous
porter atteinte
donc je crois qu'il faut bien entendu on
peut analyser individuellement les
choses mais ça ne nous amènera pas à
trouver des solutions
il ya bien sûr des solutions juridiques
militaires policiers
r mais il ya surtout une volonté de
réarmement moral c'est ça je pense qu'il
nous a beaucoup manqué c'est en cela je
crois que les mots sont importants et
moi je dirai jamais d'où les musulmans
sont des terroristes bien entendu ça
n'est pas du goût l'adresse du récit
erroné ce que veut dire réarmement moral
oui et bien l'occident est une
civilisation
en effet c'est moi je dirais plutôt une
culture parce que civilisation ça
appelle des gens qui seraient pas
civilisé non il ya plusieurs cultures et
qui n'ont pas les mêmes valeurs qui
n'ont pas les mêmes histoires l'occident
c'est à la fois bien sûr une géographie
une histoire et c'est une culture une
culture précisément du pluralisme où il
ya le pire et le meilleur
mais il ya aussi le meilleur il ya aussi
la démocratie grecque la démocratie
antique il y a le judaïsme avec tout ce
qu'il nous a apporté dans
l'interprétation l'intelligence de
l'analyse des textes il y à aussi bien
entendu les idéaux des lumières qui sont
loin d'être seulement française
il y à l'état de droit il ya l'état
providence il y a les états
redistributeur et démocratique tout ça
c'est l'occident mais l'occident
cette aussi le nazisme c'est aussi la
shoah etc dont l'occident c'est le
pluralisme
ce qui est clair c'est que l'islamisme
c'est à dire cette idéologie ce
totalitarisme islamiste lui il n'accepte
aucun pluralisme et c'est un
autoritarisme terrifiant et assassin
avait suscité avant que donne la parole
lucile williams sur youtube qui nous dit
craindre c'est générer de la peur c'est
le but des terroristes
il ne faut donc pas avoir peur et se
relever comme on l'a toujours fait oui
enfin on peut ne peux tout simplement
aussi être réaliste et savoir que iliad
et il ya un risque
voilà je crois que ce que je dis je te
dire c'est que le vocabulaire guerrier
ou le fait de dire qu'il faut mener la
guerre ne doit pas nous empêcher
d'évaluer le risque et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui
une grande majorité de français sont
conscients du risque absolu la deuxième
je peux juste jeu comme ça je parle de
de la question composé aux internautes
sur twitter et à laquelle ils sont
excessivement nombreux à répondre oui
craignez-vous la multiplication d'actes
terroristes sur le sol français vous
êtes 87% à nous répondre oui non à 13%
je voulais donc ce que je trouve très
intéressant dans ce que dit rené c'est
qu'effectivement il ya sans doute un je
sais pas si c'est un choc de
civilisations mais en tout cas il a
affirmé notre culture nos valeurs alors
nos valeurs c'est un peu ça peut
théoriquement en tout cas nos pratiques
démocratiques nos manières de faire nos
règles et c'est donc si c'est ça du
réarmement
évidemment on est d'accord après il faut
évidemment réarmer dans ce moment très
particulier où le sentiment de
catastrophe est extrêmement présent dans
l'ensemble de la société française
évidemment à cause de la pandémie
évidemment avec ce sentiment
d'impuissance dans lequel nous plonge
ses attentats parce que c'est pas comme
si gère ce sont des jeunes hommes surgi
de nulle part et qui ont regardé des
réseaux sociaux qui ont écouté des
déclarations qui ont sans doute été ont
été endoctrinés même pas sans doute et
donc à partir de là ce sentiment que
c'est extrêmement difficile de juguler
ce genre de choses c'est une moi je suis
pas tellement sur le vocabulaire de la
guerre je pense que en revanche trouver
les solutions opérationnelles en dehors
de se dire il faut des solutions
policière des solutions voilà c'est
compliqué et on est très souvent dans
les yaka fokon et le sentiment que la
puissance démocratique face au risque
terroriste existe de longue date fait
aussi partie de deux comme dirait une
sorte de dépression qu'on a en france
parce que les actes terroristes existe
de longue date aussi en france donc que
fait tout par rapport à ces actes
justement que fait-on vous parle de mode
opérationnel sur le profil de l'assassin
de l'assassin qui de l'assaillant pardon
qui est assassiné à l'armé blanche ces
deux femmes et sept hommes ce matin dans
dans la basilique notre dame à nice on
en sait un peu plus on disait c'est un
jeune homme de 21 ans originaire de
tunisie les tunisiens
selon le député des alpes maritimes eric
ciotti qui a publié un tweet un peu plus
tôt dans la journée
l'homme serait arrivé il ya très peu de
temps par lampedusa cette île italienne
qui est la porte d'entrée des migrants
en europe et eric ciotti dit plus aucune
entrée ne doit être de doit être tolérée
suspendons toutes les procédures d'asile
et la délivrance de visas depuis les
pays à risque fermeture des france des
frontières conclut-il la fermeture des
frontières est elle une solution lucine
schmidt écoutez on peut pas à la fois
invoqué la civilisation et la démocratie
et renier le droit d'asile qui est un
droit reconnu par la convention de
genève
et donc il n'est pas question à partir
de ce qui vient de se passer de renier
le droit d'asile moi j'assume
complètement de dire ça et ce qui me
frappe c'est aussi la façon dont notre
certains hauts responsables politiques à
chaque fois préconise quelque chose qui
va en fait dans le sens de l'art nîmes
en quelque part de notre état de droit
mais la question de l'analyse
opérationnelle des profils des personnes
d'avoir suffisamment de moyens humains
et financiers pour voir qui rentre au
nom du droit d'asile ça c'est un point
essentiel en ce qui concerne ce jeune
homme on ne sait pas s'il bénéficier du
droit d'asile a priori les tec en est un
mais à je ne sais pas enfin moi je
rejoins ce que dit il c'est à dire que
je rejoins parce que disait-il mais
j'observe que ciotti en tout cas fait
l'amalgamé entre être un clandestin est
un demandeur d'asile
donc on voit bien comment la question du
droit à la migration est un sujet sur
lequel on a un certain nombre de
responsables politiques qui ont utilisé
en fait le migrant pour devenir un bouc
émissaire
moi évidemment je suis entièrement
contre ce genre d' analyse on est non
non mais il faut il faut quand même
avoir le courage à gauche de poser la
question de l'immigration et il fut un
temps où l'on la pause est ça veut pas
dire renoncer aux principes du droit
d'asile
mais avoir une politique migratoire
extrêmement ouverte et massive n'est
sans doute pas une bonne solution mais
aujourd'hui nous payons des décennies
d'immigration à mon avis un contrôlé par
nous mais par contre contrôlé par les
pays d'origine et par les religieux des
pays d'origine et on a laissé donc en
france des populations sous le contrôle
et la domination d'acteurs qui n'étaient
pas des acteurs républicain et ça c'est
extrêmement grave
oui donc si vous voulez il ya un vrai
problème de la gestion migratoire
non mais alors ça ça vous mais moi je
remets pas en cause le
le droit d'asile mais mon ma grande
référence qui est léon blum on peut pas
lui reprocher d'avoir été contre le
droit d'asile mais lui même disait
effectivement le droit d'asile oui mais
pas à n'importe qui
or aujourd'hui il est dévoyée on le sait
c'est vous la réponse d'ici là je me
place que je me dépêche de répondre mais
en deux mots sur un sujet très simple
non ce que je voulais dire c'est qu'on
voit bien qu effectivement définir les
orientations d'une politique migratoire
ni à droite ni à gauche on a réussi à le
faire depuis aujourd'hui 25 en volume
est ce que vous avez dit rené où je
crois que c'était aussi très compliqué
sur le plan opérationnel
en revanche que vous dites rené sur la
question du contrôle des esprits par
l'étranger ça se fait notamment avec les
imams en ce sens la loi de lutte contre
le séparatisme que propose le
gouvernement est une loi assez
intéressante et d'ailleurs on sait qu
erdogan
pourquoi il est ce qu'il a réagi de
cette manière là parce qu'aujourd'hui il
ya une sorte de conquête des esprits
menée par un certain nombre d' imam turc
donc ça c'est pas de l'immigration
massive c'est tout simplement pour le
coup une frappe chirurgicale
je trouve ça extrêmement intéressant je
crois que mieux contrôler ce qui se
passe dans les mosquées en france faire
en sorte de savoir quel est le langage
qui sera tenue ça c'est un point
essentiel
il ya un deuxième point essentiel et ça
c'est pas ça c'est maintenant
aujourd'hui des nombreuses réduit on a
aimé la musique j'en voulais dire c'est
qu'ils sont soudain fois en dehors de la
question migratoire je crois que la
question des réseaux sociaux est une est
un sujet extrêmement grave parce que là
pour le coup il ya une politique d'
influence et le contrôle des réseaux
sociaux et de la haie du déversement de
la haine sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est un sujet sur lequel il faut se
pencher au moins autant que la politique
migratoire va passer au débat suivant
juste avant je vous lis quelques
commentaires d'internautes sur
lefigaro.fr il ya seach qui nous dit ce
n'est pas une crainte mais une certitude
conséquence directe de l'islamophobie de
nos politiques art curzi excusez moi je
ne sais pas trop lire sélection non ce
dos qui est un peu complexe
je ne crains pas les terroristes mais la
justice qui les excuses toujours et
enfin colts sur youtube pense que la
multiplication des tensions entre les
pays musulmans et la france allaient
forcément multiplier le risque d'acte
terroriste sur le sol français
doit-on craindre la multiplication
d'actes terroristes sur le sol français
mais c'est la question que vous posez
sur twitter et à laquelle on vous a
donné tout à l'heure votre participation
et vous êtes donc 87% a estimé qu' il
faut craindre la multiplication de ces
actes terroristes
passons à notre deuxième débat le
président de la république a donc
dévoilé hier soir les nouvelles mesures
de restriction et 1re confinement
nationale assorti de multiples
exceptions pour protéger les personnes
les plus fragiles mais aussi pour ne pas
mettre l'économie du pays à l'arrêt
approuvez-vous leur confinement national
adapté décidé par imen emmanuel macron
c'est la question qu'on vous pose sur
lefigaro.fr on vous donnera le résultat
de votre participation la fin de ce
deuxième débat lucile schmid
elle est réaliste réaliste et réalisable
cette solution paradoxal on peut le dire
proposé par le gouvernement sur le mode
du en même temps chers emmanuel macron
en tout cas je pense que le gouvernement
a eu raison de vouloir associer leur
confinement a plus d'activité économique
parce que ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
c'est combien la récession est là il ya
deux études de l'insee qui sont sortis
la semaine dernière et qui montrent très
clairement qu'il ya une accentuation des
inégalités extrêmement fortes de la
précarité notamment chez les personnes
qui étaient déjà en situation de
fragilité chez les ménages avec enfants
qui sont dans des niveaux de revenus
faibles on voit que les jeunes sont les
premières victimes de cette cette crise
il ya un économiste comment qui ce qui
est à l'école je retrouve plus son nom
mais qui à l'école des communes il
paraît très intéressant qui disait il ya
un effet redistributif négatif entre les
jeunes et les plus âgés dans cette
histoire là c'est à dire que quand on
est retraité on a une garantie de
revenus alors on a plus de risques
d'attraper le coc vide donc ça il faut
quand même le reconnaître c'est un
risque supplémentaire mais pour les
jeunes ça s'est traduit par une perte de
revenu
l'enfermement dans des logements la
possibilité de trouver un job quand on
en a pas donc il disait est ce que
voudrait pas faire une espèce
envisageait même une redistribution
positive à l'égard des jeunes en parlant
évidemment de ce revenu minimum
d'existence dit qui a été beaucoup
évoqué pendant le confinement donc je
trouve qu emmanuel macron a eu tout à
fait raison de l'évoquer après on attend
la façon dont jean castex va nous
expliquer les modalités pratiques parce
que chacun d'entre nous se demande
un peu comment est ce qu'il va faire
c'est à dire ne sais pas qu'est ce qui
est autorisé ou pas quelles sont les
activités dites essentielles
quand vous pouvez télétravail et vous
devez rester télétravailler mais comment
est-ce que vous allez gérer cette
articulation entre confinement
raisonnable et activités économiques et
je trouve que c'est bienvenu parce que
sinon on paiera aussi les choses en
termes de pathologies en termes de
psychiatric en termes de montée des
inégalités qui sont déjà là renée
fregosi un commentaire sur ce nouveau
confinement et les mesures adaptées qui
ont été prises par emmanuel un conte bon
le confinement tout le monde s'accorde à
le dire
étant donné l'état de la diffusion du
virus et la situation du système de
santé globale on est on y était obligé
alors après sur les modalités moi
j'aurai des remarques à faire mais ce
que ce sur quoi je voudrais insister
plus tôt puisque sinon je vais dire des
banalités de toute façon ça nous
avancera pas grand chose même si je dit
autre chose ça nous avance un temps à
grand chose d'ailleurs pas d'illusions
sur les navires
ce qui compterait vraiment c'est un
d'avoir maintenant de connaître dès
maintenant dès le début du confinement
pour nous aider nous soutenir moralement
pendant ce confinement c'est d'avoir la
stratégie du gouvernement
au sortir du confinement c'est à dire a
priori dans quatre semaines a minima ok
mais quel que soit le nombre de semaines
dans tous les cas moi je voudrais
connaître une stratégie de lutte contre
le virus c'est-à-dire contre la
diffusion et contre les les cas les plus
graves
en fait donc pour éviter un assure
troisième reconfirme ans ils vont de
lewy parce que le stop and go on en
parle beaucoup mais en fait on y est bon
donc les tests ce qu'on cherche dans un
test ce doit être les contaminants et
non pas les contaminer
c'est à dire des gens qui sont porteurs
d'une charge virale très importante qui
fait qu'ils sont contagieux et ça
les tests salivaires c'est des tests qui
ne font pas mal moi j'en ai fait un de
tests pcr dans le nez je suis une
douillette
ok mais ça fait très mal et on peut pas
le faire tout seul et ça demande du
personnel
ensuite ça demande un certain temps même
si on raccourcit le temps pourra voir le
résultat
le test salivaire il est validé il
faudrait le diffuser à massivement et
responsabiliser les gens penser que les
gens sont susceptibles de se faire des
autotests moi je les vues avec le vih en
fait les autotests ça se les gens s'en
servent très peu et c'est il ya la
question des tests et la question
également on parle les fragiles les
fragiles les gens les plus fragiles
alors on mélange à la fois les vieux les
gens qui ont des comorbidités et les
pauvres les extrêmes pauvres même qu'ils
ne peuvent pas se confiner dans de
bonnes conditions qui sont à la rue etc
etc
en fait ce qu'il faut cibler c'est les
grands contaminants vous parlez des plus
jeunes mais pas forcément les plus
jeunes mais des gens qui ont moins vu
qu'ils ont le plus de contacts avec les
autres et les lieux de grande
contamination moi je pense que des
commerces de proximité aux heures
ouvrables pour justement les retraités
qui sont les gens qui ont le plus de
moyens d'acheter des choses les laisser
faire leur course l'après midi pendant
même deux trois heures je vois pas en
quoi ça diffuserait énormément le virus
voyez par exemple bon mais peu importe
les horaires en fonction de la tranche
d'âge c'est ça non pas la tranche d'âge
du tout mais je dis deux fesc de fait
les retraités ils sont libres l'après
midi et les autres en les amis au turbin
de toute façon ils doivent bosser
vendent entre les autres ibos hockey et
ceux qui bossent pas ils peuvent faire
un peu marcher le commerce vous voyez
par exemple mais c'est surtout qu'il
nous faut une stratégie pour le moyen
terme parce que le long terme on espère
quand même avoir un magasin maxent et où
des traitements
moi il me semble
par rapport à ce que dit rené c'est
qu'effectivement la question de la du
cap est un point essentiel après que le
gouvernement donne un cap
alors qu'en même temps on connaît si je
puis dire on ne connaît pas bien ce
virus en fait bon il faut qu'il donne un
cap et que par ailleurs ils soient
suffisamment flexible pour s'adapter par
rapport à ce qu'on voit de l'évolution
des courbes épidémique mais surtout ce
qui me semble manquer fâcheusement
actuellement on l'a beaucoup dit mais je
trouve que c'est très fort dans cette
deuxième vague c'est l'élan même l'élan
de solidarité ou le fait de croire qu'on
va s'en sortir
dire qu'on voit bien que prend vous
l'avez doit se trouver assez optimiste
ah c'est vrai j'en parlais pas emmanuel
macron je parlais de nous en général en
fait je parlais de la société française
emmanuel macron je pense qu'il a fait un
secteur qui voit là je pense qu'il faut
pas tout attendre des manuels macron ça
on n'a compris ni du gouvernement je
crois qu'il faut attendre beaucoup de
choses de notre responsabilité
collective et qu'on a du mal à calibrer
cette responsabilité collective par
rapport à notre responsabilité
individuelle chacun se dit mais j'ai
fait mon possible mais est-ce que c'est
pas les autres c'est intéressant ce que
vous avez la responsabilité en 2009 en
entend peu oui on tape à bras raccourcis
sur le gouvernement avant les
scientifiques qui ont raconté parfois
des bêtises sur les plateaux en disant
que c'est eux les responsables du fait
qu' on arrive à cette situation de
renault évidemment aujourd'hui est ce
que nos responsabilités individuelles ne
sont pas en cause aujourd'hui on
entendait richard ferrand ce matin qui
disait que si on tombait malade
aujourd'hui aussi vous tombiez malas et
est de votre responsabilité vous n'avez
pas fait attention à temps et il
non mais c'est parfait oui et qu'il
arrête parce qu'on aime bien discuter
avec un médecin on s'aperçoit qu'à sa
nombre de gens sont tous malades
personnes tombent malades sans savoir
justement comme le disait rené qui les a
contaminés donc au fond l'un des enjeux
actuellement c'est qu'on n'a mesuré avec
la deuxième vague que ce virus était
hyper contagieux beaucoup plus même que
ce qu'on pensait effectivement il ya des
supers contaminateur ça on le sait aussi
après les scientifiques ou les médecins
enfin tous ceux qui sont censés savoir
avouent leur ignorance ce à quoi je
retiens aussi c'est à dire qu'on est
dans ce billet mais c'est aussi une
posture impasse comme à l'humilité des
grands des grands noms de la médecine
ont pas mal et ça m'énerve avec un corps
dont les ansériens s'il faut aller un
bioshock mais ce qu'on sait c'est qu'en
tout cas collectivement si je puis me
permettre
il faut qu'on soit aussi qu'on
reconnaisse aussi qui assemble le
mystère avec ce virus qui reste là
effectivement examiner les lieux où il
ya des supers contamination comme
ç'avait été le cas vous savez un mur
vous autour de 7 ce rassemblement
carrière et ça c'est intéressant
donc il faut peut-être aller plus sur
les cas pratiques que faire des grands
discours et puis c'est vrai que le
confinement c'est une arme massive et
que le sujet c'est le déconfinement
ensuite comment est ce qu'on fait quand
on déconfite de façon à ne par confiner
parce que au fond c'est ça qui nous
désespère un pervis et qu'on a le
sentiment qu'on a des confiné et qu'on
avait été très raisonnable et puis qu'en
fait ça repart beaucoup plus fort encore
donc il ya une question pour nous
expliquer au fond les scénarios qui a
devant nous pourquoi ne pas expliquer à
l'ensemble des français les scénarios
qui a devant nous c'est la
responsabilité collective ou
individuelle on l'activé aussi dans une
communication qui fait confiance aux
autres sans vouloir dire des choses trop
cucul la praline oui tout à fait on nous
a plutôt déresponsabiliser les
responsabiliser et l'autoritarisme
punitif ça déresponsabilise les gens on
les a pas responsabilisés on leur a pas
dit voilà mais pas vous allez contaminer
votre grand mère n'ont pas pas menacé et
pas culpabiliser à responsabiliser les
gens vous êtes responsable de votre
corps de votre et caetera et se recentre
et justement dans une perspective
individualiste qui est celle qui est
aujourd'hui l'état d'esprit général mais
justement utiliser le bon côté de
l'individualisme pour responsabiliser
les gens alors à propos de
responsabiliser les gens gabriel atta le
porte parole du gouvernement donner un
petit conseil ce matin sur rtl on écoute
ici on acheter tout ce qu'un livre
demain c'est à dire aujourd'hui c'est
vrai chacun des auditeurs qui nous
écoutent qui le peut et qui le veut
aujourd'hui avant de rentrer chez lui
passe chez son libraire achète un livre
moi c'est ce que je vais faire
non seulement c'est un geste financier
mais c'est aussi une manière de dire à
nos libraires qui évidemment nous serons
avec eux quand ils rouvriront et que
nous serons au rendez vous
l'aspect sanitaire oui l'aspect
économique évidemment est très important
et donc ce geste économique vous le
ferez pour mémoire vous passerez dans
une librairie acheter un livre lui déjà
fait hier mais mais il suffisait de
laisser les librairies ouverte dans
l'après midi
ça non je crois qu'il ya effectivement
dans ce que dit c'est très intéressant
on est totalement d'accord là dessus
c'est de trouver la souplesse et la
souplesse existe à partir du moment où
la responsabilité individuelle et
collective est activée et en fait ce
qu'il faut remarquer c'est que dans le
premier confinement y avait une forme
d'autoritarisme
la france est le pays qui a connu le
confinement le plus autoritaire par
rapport à ses voisins c'est pas pour
envoi que l'autoritarisme n'a pas joué
vraiment sur les chiffres ceux qui
jouent c'est évidemment l'état du
système de santé et puis les facteurs de
contamination nos systèmes de santé peut
être excellent s'il ya des supers
contamination
voilà ça n'empêchera rien donc tout ce
sujet aujourd'hui c'est comment au fond
dans le discours d' emmanuel macron tout
le monde a trouvé très pédagogique c'est
vrai il l'était mais comment est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui dans les modalités
pratiques
les choses sont suffisamment souple pour
nous permettre de vivre et d'être
responsable et là dedans il suffit pas
de dire les écoles sont ouvertes et vous
pourrez travailler donc le pibe pourra
remonter parce qu'au fond ce que chacun
d'entre nous recenser qui se sent à la
fois acteur économique responsable
personne qui veut que la santé du pays
aille mieux
et puis qui veut aussi que ses proches a
mieux c'est à dire que au fond il faut
réconcilier
l'appel à la responsabilité du
gouvernement avec la réalité des
pratiques et reconnaître que les
français se comportent plutôt bien
c'est très loin de la fin pour vous les
6 mètres une petit un petit mot de
conclusion pour vous nommez est
absolument et qu'ils prennent en main
leur santé individuelle et qu'on leur
donne enfin des autotests de sale hiver
ça aiderait beaucoup on a bien compris
votre message
merci beaucoup à tous les deux devraient
vous faire part des commentaires des
internautes sur ce débat numéro 2 sur 6
sites ch sur lefigaro.fr nous dit leur
confinement pourquoi pas mais quand on
confine ça ne doit pas être à moitié en
laissant tous les jeunes allaient à
l'école comme si de rien n'était pauline
pense que les jeunes sont très souvent
accusée de propager le virus et ne
comprends pas qu'il ne soit pas confiné
autant que le reste de la population
c'est ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
nicole sur youtube nous dit l'économie
n'est pas la priorité il faut cesser de
sacrifier nos concitoyens je crois que
c'est un peu
la politique qui essaye de mener le
gouvernement ait enfin pragma nous dit
que le gouvernement cherche le compromis
le moins coûteux en fonction de la
situation sanitaire il ne reconfirme
sûrement pas de gaieté de coeur c'est ce
qu'on disait c'est le et en même temps
qui essaye de pratiquer sur ce
confinement emmanuel macron merci encore
à tous de nous avoir suivi merci à
toutes les deux d'avoir été en direct
avec nous et d'avoir des battus vous
suivrez évidemment l'intervention du
premier ministre
pardon jean castex
excusez moi qui donnera les modalités
détaillées de ce en quoi consiste leur
confinement et nous on se dit à très
vite sur figaro live
[Musique]